merci d'être venus aussi nombreux mais
avant de commencer j'aurais souhaité
qu'on me donne une bouteille d'eau en
fin d'après-midi à tous soit je pense
l'envoyé ce geste est tout à fait banale
tout à fait ordinaire en fait est lourd
de signification pour un certain nombre
de personnes sur terre celle en
bouteille et c'est de l'eau potable
aujourd'hui il y a près de 1 milliard de
personnes qui n'ont pas accès qui n'a
pas accès à l'eau potable et on sait que
d'ici 2050 et de dire la population
mondiale seront exposés de sécheresses
récurrentes de façon inéluctable
changement climatique
c'est un paramètre réellement aggravant
qui combinait à une population
croissante voyais un petit peu les
chiffres absolument inédit dans
l'histoire de l'humanité
le dernier siècle a vu sa population
passer de 500 millions à peu près a
maintenant 6 6 milliards 7 milliards
bientôt 9 milliards
ça c'est comme la pose des défis qui
sont je dirais un sens et on a
réellement tous les ingrédients d'une
catastrophe parfaite et on n'y échappera
pas ce sont des problèmes qui a falloir
résoudre ce sont des questions qui
demandent une réponse et on a une chance
quand même qu'inwi c'est que toutes les
eaux de surface qui ont servi au
développement la civilisation les lacs
et les rivières
eh bien elles sont 30 fois plus petit
que les eaux profondes que les eaux qui
sont au-delà des 50 100 m 150 m
autrement dit il y a des ressources
énormes qui sont encore cachés et ses
ressources énormes
eh bien c'est ce qu'on appelle le du
futur
parce que l'autre surface avec toutes
les avec tous avec développement des six
assure que le développement d'industries
avec je dirais le manque de respect que
l'homme a que l'humanité a payé pour
l'eau des rivières polluées
l'industrialisation la concentration
urbaine les auteurs faso pollué et
encore une fois je dirais que le
changement climatique est un phénomène
aggravant avec combiné à cette
démographie
donc on a cette solution nos profonds
mais comment la trouver et où la trouver
ça reste encore une des grandes
questions qui ne sont pas vraiment tout
à fait résolus et en fait je suis
d'abord pétroliers je vais pas parler de
moi j'ai simplement vous parlez des 14
dernières années de ma vie où ma vie a
totalement basculé du côté de l'eau
obsédé par cette par ce défi qui bien
qu'il va bien falloir résoudre est en
fait c'est par un pur accident que j'ai
découvert quelque chose extrêmement
intéressant on travaillant pour un
projet pétrolier en libye
voilà une image satellite avec du bassin
de syrte au sud au sud de
de syrte en libye et j'ai découvert ça
en utilisant du radar par satellite et
sera là par satellite a quelque chose d
extrêmement intéressant c'est d'abord il
couvre simultanément de très grandes
surfaces sur la terre et que le
rayonnement radar est très sensible à
l'eau la l'humidité des sols et ce qu'on
voit c'est une énorme c'est pas une
tâche et un martinez il fut-il un
d'humidité tout à fait évoqua très
évocateurs d'une d'une fuite
le long d'un pipe lines qui convoyait
qui convoie de l'eau sur les grandes
capitales et on voit cette brillance qui
correspond aux vibrations des molécules
d'eau dans le sol excité par vraiment
radars je prends l'exemple d'une
baguette de pain que vous voulez
réchauffer au micro ondes ou l'a sorti
du congélateur vous la mettez en demies
gronde en général c'est un désastre
parce que la croûte et froide et lamy
est bouillante
pourquoi parce que dans la croûte ya pas
d'humidité ya pas de libration molécule
elle va rester froide ce qui correspond
aux partis noirs de l'image et la mie de
pain qui chauffe et bouillante ça
corresponde partie brillante mais sur
cette image là il ya aussi des zones de
brillance qui ne sont pas d'humidité et
donc je me suis accroché à cette image
en disant il faut aller plus loin il
faut dépasser ce qui est donné et
essayer de trouver un moyen de se
débarrasser de tous les obstacles de
surface en ne maintenant que l'humidité
profonde et si jamais on arrive à 7 à
cette performance
si on trouve le bon algorithme eh bien
on va pouvoir commencer à travailler
sérieusement pour la recherche de ces
aquifères profonds
voilà donc une cartographie de cette
grande rivière artificielle 4000 km de
tube qui exploite de l'eau profonde un
des bassins sédimentaires du sud de la
libye lé bassin de koufra le bassin
marzouk il bassin de syrte
et voyez la taille la taille des tuyaux
donc et qui vous donne une idée des
quantités d'eau qui sont transportés des
quantités d'eau qui sont perdus c'est de
l'eau fossile set jo qui a 26 26 à 28
bilan qui se renouvellent très très peu
donc c'est une eau qu'il faut protéger
donc j'ai montré cette image à kadhafi
au cours d'une mission qui a sursauté
qu'un étranger qui n'avait jamais mis
les pieds en libye et soit capable de
voir cette fidèle à localiser surtout
très précisément et je pensait récupérer
un beau contrat de surveillance de ses
4000 kilomètres de paille par satellite
en fait j'ai fait une grave erreur
kadhafi a très mal pris ces résultats il
a décapité la direction hydraulique de
benghazi donc je me suis quasiment enfui
de libye mais dans ma fuite je me suis
dit que je touchais là quelque chose est
vraiment important et que peut-être que
cette image de fuite me donnerait l'idée
de découvrir des aquifères nouveau voilà
donc c'est comme ça qu'est né le concept
loup avec soitec se dire ou encore
exploration à partir de cette expérience
qui étaient faites en 2002 et pendant
deux ans j'ai creusé réellement le sujet
tentez algorithmes après à gori de
traitement d'image du traitement d'image
ce sont des équations mathématiques
c'est pareil les bruits de surface de de
l'humilité profonde et pour arriver au
bout de deux ans donc en 2004 juste
avant la crise du darfour à cette image
voilà une image qui plein d'obstacles de
surface mais qui aussi plein d'humilité
bas bien qu'on soit en plein désert il
ya de l'humidité mais on la voit pas
elle est cachée par les obstacles de
surface est donc cet algorithme va
permettre d'enlever tous les obsèques du
refah de surface jusqu'à 20 mètres de
profondeur et aboutir à cette image
c'est exactement au même endroit et on
voit dès qu'on découvre là à ce moment
là l'ensemble de dendrite presque des
fractales qui correspondent à un réseau
fossiles qui continuent à fonctionner en
sous sol jusqu'à
60 80 mètres de profondeur et quand j'ai
découvert cette image là je dis mais
comment est-ce possible que les gens
meurent de soif au darfour il ya de nous
partout natation faut bien viser parce
que ça c'est comme la baguette qui sort
du conte chose qui sort du micro-ondes
le noir c'est absolument sec c'est froid
bien sûr là ou là où c'est brillant ya
l'humidité c'est la [ __ ] pas les choses
et c'est à partir de cette image là que
je me suis dit on peut y aller on peut
maintenant aller sur le terrain pour
aider les populations qui sont en train
de mourir
il a fait image là c'était quatre jours
enfin quinze jours avant que le haut
commissariat des réfugiés à genève
m'appelle jeune âge anticipé cette
application mais après il faut sauter de
la théorie à la pratique
là jusqu'à présent j'avais la tête dans
les étoiles ça m'a permis de mettre au
point le concept mathématiques
maintenant pour lui donner de la valeur
tant que c'est pas fort et mon idée elle
vous 0
tant que j'ai pas prouver la validité
des résultats ce que j'ai fait ne vaut
rien c'est étayé techniquement mais
l'objectif ultime c'est de sauver des
gens trouver de l'eau et l'eau potable
et puis voilà les scènes de guerres
auxquelles on est confronté auquel on
n'est pas du tout préparé bien sûr c'est
pas mon métier je suis pas casques bleus
de l'onu et encore moins militaire et
puis on à faire un drame d'une très très
grande magnitude la licorne sont
répartis plus sur plus de 600 km de long
le long de la frontière entre le tchad
et soudan là au départ
deux cent cinquante mille réfugiés côté
tchadien 3 millions de personnes
déplacées
de l'autre côté qui vont pas tout l'eau
et camionné ça coûte des millions de
dollars aux nations unies parce qu'il
faut bien il maintenir ces populations
en vie mais c'est une catastrophe
économique
et c'est une catastrophe humaine sans
compter qu'on opère dans un contexte est
extrêmement dangereux
avec différentes factions qui
s'affrontent et qui vous prennent en
otage mois pour eux je suis un ennemi
parce que j'apporte le progrès j'apporte
l'espoir et eux ne travaillent que sur
désespoir des gens pour contrôler
d'immenses territoires pour leur trafic
c'est bien de ça dont il s'agit et voilà
finalement le bataillon mongols des
casques bleus google qui m'ont qui m'ont
permis de travailler pendant un mois
dans cette partie reculée du tchad
donc c'est quand même très coûteux en
sécurité et est relativement dangereux
mais le résultat c'est ça le l'eau
potable et pour condamner la libido
potable il n'avait jamais dansé avec
l'eau avant et et surtout en moins de
six mois
on a couvert on a épluché comme un
oignon la surface du tchad et du soudan
sur deux cent mille kilomètres carrés
pour vraiment faire l'inventaire des
ressources déployées les foreurs de
l'unicef qui pendant deux ans ou forêts
1700 puis qui est quand même un effort
financier considérable à part de la
communauté internationale
avec un taux de succès de forage qui est
passée de 33% à 98%
donc ça a été ça a été perçu comme une
véritable révolution au niveau de
l'exploration de ces ressources qui ma
foi à cette époque là était pas très
profonde puisqu'il s'agissait de socle
est le socle était au maximum à 80
mètres de profondeur les choses se sont
corsées quand en 2011
il ya une sécheresse épouvantable qui a
ravagé toute la corne de l'afrique et le
nord et le nord du kenya en particulier
et donc là des centaines de milliers de
têtes de troupeaux sont mortes et quand
on sait que les troupeaux il s'agit de
peuples passe aux migrants quand on sait
que un homme fait est en charge à peu
près de dix bêtes si les bêtes meurent
l'omr puisque c'est la seule ressource
alimentaire qu'ils aient non pas qu'ils
mangent le bétail pas du tout ils le
respectent de trop
ils boivent leur lait il récupère le
sang sur la jugulaire qui côté réalise
aussi aussitôt donc il ne tue pas le
bétail au contraire mais ils vivent en
symbiose avec leurs animaux et quand on
voit ça en images on imagine le drame
humain qui se produit derrière et là on
est dans des conditions beaucoup plus
difficile qu'au tchad parce que des
aquifères sont plus profonds on
imaginait un moment donné qu'ils
pouvaient descendre jusqu'à 1 ou 2 km et
quand le travail d'exploration de
filtrage de terrain a été fait sur les
images radar surprise émotion intense
une possibilité de cinq aquifère
totalement inconnu entre 200 et 600
mètres de profondeur dont à celui du
nord qui a taillé de la belle de la
moitié la belgique sur lequel il n'y
avait aucun forage c'est justement le
lieu où à peu des territoires disputés
entre l'ouganda le sud soudan l'éthiopie
le kenya où les populations pastorales
s'affrontent autour des puits comme dans
la bible le point d'eau quand il ya peu
d'eau c'est la guerre
et quand j'ai vu la taille possible
possible vous le prouver maintenant de
ces acquis faire enfin on va peut-être
pouvoir créer la paix les conditions de
paix parce que beaucoup d'eau si paul au
sénat hier beaucoup d'eau
chances d'aboutir à la paix on se tue
pas par plaisir
si on arrive à faire suffisamment depuis
sur ces immensités désertiques
eh bien chacun ira alimenter son propos
sans avoir un trucider le voisin et
effectivement le premier forage a donné
très très beau résultat il a fallu les
sols comme jusqu'à 400 m qui est tout à
fait inédit et on m'a traité de fou
quand j'ai proposé le premier forage
dans cette zone là les gens commencent à
réfléchir quand ils ont vu que ça
marchait
les résultats se sont toutes les femmes
turkana atteint son but joule l'eau
jaillir se sont spontanément réunis
autour de moi pour me faire la fête
parce que sans cet ol ont une vie de
chien
elles font 40 km par jour à pied avec
leur chien leur enfant tombé de l'eau et
quand elles ont vu ça l ont bien compris
que la vie leur vie allait changer
totalement changé ce qui est important
c'est de voir qu'avec cette innovation
technologique
il est possible de transformer un enfer
paradis et quand j paradis c'est
vraiment le cas des femmes de cette
communauté de la capitale de vars que je
voyais faire les poubelles en 2000 en
2011 2012 on nourrir leurs enfants
maintenant peuvent vivre dignement
élever leurs enfants et les nourrir
correctement et nourrir leurs chèvres
abreuver leurs chèvres les soirs c'est
modeste mais ça va agrandir en espérant
que ça va devenir une californie alors
là soyons prudents en contrôle ont bien
le taux de dépression de cet aquifère et
ce remplissage
c'est la règle un aquifère c'est comme
un compte en banque
on doit équilibrer les entrées les
sorties si on néglige cet aspect là on
va à la faillite
la faillite pour un privé s'est
éventuellement la prison là c'est la
mort c'est autrement plus sérieux donc
ce phénomène de remplissage de
renouvellement des ressources et examens
portant mais on le mesure aussi avec
avec nos méthodes
autrement dit avec cette nouvelle vision
ce changement de paradigme par rapport à
la recherche traditionnelle de
ressources en eau profonde
eh bien on peut complètement changer la
vie des gens et ont peu changé quasiment
le monde c'est possible parce que ces
réserves la découverte par accident au
kenya parce qu'on m'a demandé de le
faire mais actuellement on fini de
travailler sur l'irak en banque en
débordant sur la syrie on découvre des
choses aussi extrêmement extrêmement
intéressante riche riche d'avenir qui
vont permettre effectivement de
stabiliser de reconstruire un certain
nombre de sociétés détruite par ce
changement de thématiques qui a aussi
entraîné la guerre des guerres
régionales dégâts tribales donc cette
sécheresse là elle est dévastatrice au
niveau des rapports entre communautés et
c'est pour ça devant ces résultats que
la fondation de l'espace qui est une
émanation la nasa m'a remis il ya
quelques quelques semaines ce prix pour
ce système bettex watteau l'exploration
et pour en considérant trois facteurs
principaux
il fallait pour recevoir ce prix
utilisez techniques spatiales créé à
partir d'essais de ces technologies
spatiales quelque chose d'innovant qui
sert à la promotion de l'humanité et il
fallait il fallait quantifier cette
promotion donc sauver la vie de plus de
1 million de personnes là je suis à peu
près à 30 et
et et j'espère que c'est pas fini
j'espère que pas fini parce que c'est
bien d'avoir prouvé qu'un système marche
mais c'est encore mieux de drainer de
faire adhérer la communauté des hommes
des dirigeants à ce progrès qui réel
parce que là je suis au nord de l'irak
devant un camp de réfugiés c'est
malheureux sont entassés dans des camps
sans sans vision sans sans espoir est ce
que j'espère c'est que et j'ai été en
irak pour ça justement c'est de pouvoir
aider lorsque la paix soit revenue dieu
sait comme mais elle viendra de pression
il manque ablement faute faute de
combattants à la fin malheureusement il
faudra reconstruire et la reconstruction
elle sera faite essentiellement à partir
de l'eau de l'agriculture parce que ces
populations il faut les il faut les
nourrir il faut les abreuver c'est
vraiment la clé la clé l'énergie l'eau
et les sols
c'est vraiment le triangle vertueux qui
va permettre cette renaissance d
humanité qui ont été totalement
détruites par ses guerres voilà le
message d'espoir que je voulais vous
laisser vous qui êtes futurs ingénieurs
ou des ingénieurs